hello there guys we've recently just got
our first look at season two of the
mandalorian
from entertainment weekly with newly
released images
and information revealed about a season
from the cast and crew
but as i go through this information
you're going to see the images play in
the background so you guys can enjoy
that
so the first season concluded with mando
embarking on a search for the child's
own kind
and gideon was revealed to possess the
mysterious
ancient dark saber so this makes me
believe that a part of season 2
is going to showcase mando searching for
the child's or
yoda species to possibly return him or
something like that which i have a
feeling he probably won't end up doing
but i did actually hear that the child
or
baby yoda's name will actually be
revealed in this season
which leads me to believe that you know
we'll actually see yoda's species and
then his name will be revealed from
you know one of their own kind but to be
honest with you
if his name does get revealed i do think
people are still going to call him baby
oda
because you know come on it's just too
much of an iconic name to let go
so you know it'll be hard to start
calling him by his actual name
anyway john favreau here says the new
season is about
introducing a larger story in the world
the stories become less
isolated yet each episode has its own
flavor and hopefully we bring in a lot
more to the scope of the show
adds felony everything gets bigger the
stakes get higher
but also the personal story between the
child and the mandalorian
develops in a way i think people will
enjoy and while the first season's
episodes were very strictly focused on
mando season 2 adds new storytelling
angles as we introduce
other characters their opportunities to
follow different storylines
john says okay so this is actually quite
exciting to me
because i think this kind of low-key
confirms we will be getting the rumored
characters ahsoka
boba fett boca time and rex
it is possible we won't get these
characters but i do believe we'll at
least get some of them like ahsoka and
boba fett or at least i hope so but do
you guys remember the end of episode 5
to gunslinger there was that mysterious
character
shown which i do have a feeling is boba
fett
but you know we're gonna have to wait
and see mando and a child are pursued by
moth gideon
who will serve as a source of temptation
in the classic tradition of star wars
villains
trying to lure heroes down darker paths
i'll be going toe-to-toe with mando says
esposito
it's an iconic battle i want to disarm
him mentally as well
who knows maybe there's an opportunity
to get him to fight some battles for me
you may think i'm a villain
but i'm trying to harness some energy
and some powers for a path that could be
best for all
you get to see him be somewhat
diplomatic and more of a manipulator
honestly this is really interesting to
me because you think moth get in is you
know just a villain
but it sounds like he's something more
than that we do know he is hunting and
he really wants you know the child baby
yoda
we don't know why he wants him but i'm
sure that will be revealed in season two
and it sounds like he's trying to
manipulate mando and
somewhat maybe successful of this so i'm
guessing moff gideon actually knows
more about shinjarin than we think and
more of his past will be revealed
in season two and i'm guessing this will
be used against dungeon and
you know manipulate him to do stuff that
he probably wouldn't normally do
and for that dark saber in the new
episodes gideon demonstrates his quite
adapt a world in it
it's so exciting for me to be in a show
where i can wear a cape and own it
and where i can have a lightsaber and
really own it
says esposito he'll also command a
larger vehicle
and spend some one-on-one time with the
child okay so this is also quite
exciting and interesting to me
um without larger vehicle the first
thing that came to mind
is an 8080 so i do have a thrill and it
could be that but honestly
it could mean anything so i got no clue
and also he said he's going to spend
one on one time with the child which
i don't know that's scary and exciting
um that means he's out of hands of the
mandalorian or possibly he's
taken hostage or i got no clue what's
happening here but it's
you know quite enticing because we know
gideon wants
you know the child it sounds like he has
some one-on-one time with him
so what is that one-on-one time we got
no clue
but i don't know but i'm looking forward
to it i'm really looking forward to
season two
um let me know in the comment section
below if you want more commentary videos
like this
and also got a question for you guys
what are you most looking forward to in
season 2 of the mandalorian so let me
know in the comment section below and
may it a force
be with you
you